I do think Trump's greatest single
potential opportunity
is to run as the peace candidate as
Eisenhower said I will end the war in
Korea Nixon said I will end the war in
Vietnam given the Middle Eastern peace
deal which Trump got done which no one
thought possible given the fact that it
was Trump who turned off the Russian
Pipeline and Trump who gave the
offensive weapons to the ukrainians that
Obama would not give them given Trump's
diplomatic success success in North
Korea where he at least got the Mad ban
to to stop his nuclear weapons to uh
development testing which is now
restarted under Joe Biden I mean I think
he has credibility as a deal maker as a
negotiator
[Music]
[Applause]